you
5000 a lot of late miniatures Ferraris
in there Keane is in there 56 players
all right we are officially kicked off
let's get some free moves in here and
let's make sure we get developed really
fast castle occupy the open file
let's fly here first
mm let's go with this move let's trade
once and not do that I was ready to
blunder some stuff there this nights
gonna be a pain I'm dropping upon oh
that's painful that was awful oh no that
was terrible Bishop takes pawn I already
feel like this is reasonable it is
reasonable oh my goodness I should
resign yeah I should resign why am I not
resigning this is reasonable oh my
goodness that was terrible why did I
take their night night at Knight takes
c6 only help the rook who okay let's get
that one let's let's forget about that
one really really fast I'm still in the
tournament right okay okay shake that
one off if you're gonna lose a game
that's the one to lose it's happened
before it will happen again and let's
stay focused stay focused would you
alright chances are you could maybe
encounter that opponent again you want
to be able to get him back let's secure
f5 throw my knight in there take with
the Jeep on if Bishop takes Queen b6
first maybe to control the dark squares
why are they not moving okay let's give
this no no no right here or watch out
for a sneak attacks Knight g6 Knight g3
can be deadly that Knight moves take
here let's stop b4
you still might play this to stay on the
diagonal trade light square Bishop
Bishop a6 I'd like to have a light
square bishop exchange that means my
knight on f5 will live there down a lot
of time okay let's get this trade in I
guess take with the Queen put pressure
on their night in fact I'll be
threatening Queen takes Knight after
Bishop takes Bishop Queen takes Knight
okay
the knight is pinned okay I got the rook
there and let's just move forward I'm
hitting the b2 pond I could've just
taken the beet soup on there down a lot
of time though it's not gonna matter
just anything take the Queen nope okay
they're down on time back to tournament
land okay I have no I Oh again already
okay this guy's gonna try and give me
another beating let's try and stop some
early beatings here maybe get rid of my
LightSquared bishop no they're not gonna
allow that trade to happen so easily huh
I get rid of their night okay gotta get
rid of that guy he's not going into the
night quietly okay tough day at the
office here after babysit this pawn not
fun at all okay this is getting broken
down big-time
oh this is painful my bishop is goodness
let me hit that resigning button let's
not make a habit out of that this guy's
crushing me man okay just get it back on
the horse that's all you could do that
was brutal brutal okay let's let's keep
going here somehow just stay away from
that guy leave me alone man leave me
alone what'd I do to deserve that that
was a very painful Fork okay watch out
for discoveries
yeah okay let's stop thief or maybe e5
or d5 no I'll keep moving forward maybe
they'll take you and then you can move
forward
rook c1 okay my bishops in a good spot
let's improve my queen position and I
guess here not really sure why they're
okay they're gonna play pawn push yeah
they are
alright let's I got a challenge that
Bishop he's too good okay Bishop d3
Queen here threatening me I could use a
quick mate rook c1 watch out for hope
chess
watch out for hope Chazz repetition No
all right they have a weakened second
rank let's move forward
Queen trade the cost of a structural
defect yes threatening to maybe take the
bishop then pin tactics not quite here
now they have have the majority over
here two to one majority they're down on
time though let's keep them in a pin I
should play Bishop here sooner let's do
it now they have to crawl up into a ball
pawn push oh I was helpful though
they're down on they're down on time
back to tournament Oh - OH - I have no
idea who's in the lead I can't have my
suspicions all right yeah I could maybe
guess who's in the lead where's the top
I am on page three you got to get the
first Oh the leader boys over here you
goof it's been that long since I played
internment I don't know where the
leaderboard is okay ah man really really
you're trying to just snipe my queen
like that what did I do to deserve that
I kind of hit him back with a fork night
here Queen check two pieces are hit
let's take the free one and
look and move fast I think I need to
just throw in some pre moves even if I'm
dropping material even if I'm gonna drop
some material I need to get some pre
moves in how else are you gonna try and
fight back I mean really all right
don't drop your queen whatever you do
don't drop your queen 26 seconds I'm
just gonna give the piece back oh I
wasn't expecting that move okay I got to
stop the reap on from moving maybe get
the c5 square recapturing my queen okay
whoa they're not taking that piece back
I think takes Bishop with check maybe
another check I'm hitting their queen
just keep it closed f6 soon let's break
it open takes her down a lot of time I
didn't mean to do that here and push
anything they're down on time back his
hermit 6 I know you know what the
leaderboard wasn't there
I had actually okay scratch that I
didn't mean to do that
here we go yeah your pieces out fast
let's hang on to that guy all right this
was maybe not correct okay I might have
messed and made it needs to do a d6
sooner okay let's get my bishop out
oh look active if I can move why wasn't
i moving there okay flight square all
right that was helpful I take my knight
got to watch over the d5 square oh here
comes a pesky Knight Queen here first
and then c6 okay let's get there dark
square bishop and then play this move my
knight might get to d4 and he'd be
enormous he's
going to get to d4 there's this wave as
well although bishop in that's probably
going to be strong they didn't go for it
trying to invade now let's secure my
night position time is pretty good here
for my opponent get to the seventh
ranked night check not quite working
I'll watch out for double check ooh
they really walked right into that one
and now this will be made they resigned
back to tournament ooh guess what I'm on
the front page it feels good it feels
very good seventh lucky number seven how
much time is left in this 20 minutes
plenty of time plenty of time I should
have maybe gone for this maneuver before
castling with my knight could have saved
a tempo maybe alright b5 is never
happening what am I really thinking of
here okay here here's a plan get rid of
their dark square Bishop and okay maybe
even the Queen's get my knight in to f4
mm-hmm no that's a juicy square that at
Foursquare I'm hitting the bishop King
here watch out for h3 I'll take that guy
and let's take once more
it's another pond on the rook as well
let's go here get another free move in I
think I could do this kind of pre move
nothing nothing tricky happening okay
I'm still hoping for something here it's
their king they're in a pin maybe get g6
f5 their rook their Bishop can now move
mmm alright we're going to take like
this I'd really like to see them take
that straighten up my pawns and I don't
know let's give a check come over here
give it check like this and then secure
the e4 square okay they're going to give
a knight check first they should have
given
night check their Bishop is completely
under control and now I could get this
moving with tempo my pawns continue to
push pawn push except if they take here
and let's do this first okay mate
happening soon they have a pawn they
could move on to and that'll be game
back to tournament
oh man that guy's on a tear did he knock
out Ferrari twice as well 3427 1916 man
14 is where I stand this is a race well
feels like a race for a third place
okay maybe maybe I could call in a
fishing pole stuff then we're gonna see
we're gonna see about that okay can I
get this advance in you know push get
this guy in let's make them struggle a
little bit to get d4 and rookie rook d1
let's just stop that advance all
together expose this pawn he's a bit
disconnected now I see four comes with
tempo let's just return back here anyhow
pressure on this pond try to get b5 in
right away okay let's stop there Knight
from getting active yeah okay so they
have a very nice grip over the position
let's let's play over on this wing get
some trades in I'm whacking well I have
a space advantage but also a
disadvantage on the King side not sure
what to do let's sneak my knight in to
c3 that's a plan that's a juicy square
get to the juicy squares watch out for
Bishop takes h6 recapture with the Queen
let's take care move forward give check
grab this pawn next night here would
have been beautiful let's do it now and
take with which Knight none of the above
I think the Queen is close to being
trapped move forward
I should have taken the Brooke take
material first man she's free stuff huh
not here fortunately my Bishop's around
okay let's get a queen trade another
check now we're gonna take a rook
finally well done you took a free piece
how's the clock situation okay I've got
a piece there it's this Knight up to no
good as usual they resigned back to
tournament 16 minutes remain we're not
even at the halfway point this guy
remains on fire I'm at eighteen thirty
eight twenty eight nineteen eighteen
eighteen eighteen sixteen just very
happy to be on the front page well more
to say how many more mouths lips how
many more mouths lips Scotch planned Oh
watch out for that move huh
okay have much experience with this well
we're gonna give it a whirl I'm gonna
give up a pond and look to smash open
their king that's a good start and
that's a freebie let's open it up
keep the Queen's on the board don't say
that too often queenside castle why not
two birds with one stone
King safety not quite king safety and
rook activity let's move forward keep
moving forward let's sack a night
because you could it's open the position
up watch out for H too soon to be made
on h2 very close very very close getting
even closer Queen h5 mate threat
difficult to parry unpair evil uh yeah
unpair evil there's a new one what am i
doing I'm dropping another piece still
threatening me with the silly pawn watch
out pawn got him back to tournament
forty three thirty twenty two oh I'm in
third all right here we go
I'd see three let's see if they give me
the bishop pair he's gonna try and turn
into an animal let's see if that happens
watch out for the dark square bishop
he's gonna try to become an animal
the unopposed bishop he could be very
dangerous he's gonna try to be dangerous
a knight on f5 sacrifices on g7 right
around the corner
he's a beast here two beasts Knight and
Bishop I'm okay with trading knight on
f5 let's keep my queen on this diagonal
Knight f5 stuff is happening on g7 it's
getting serious I want to support my
night with g4 and then look for
something interesting
let's get Eve foreign there we go my
knight is definitely secure now let's
stop Knight g5 I could have taken on a
g7 but close to happening something
exciting here in g7 on flesh let's break
it open open up the H file here comes my
rook watch out for me it's he needs to
just go let's crash through on h7 and
then h8 the dark squares big trouble
mate happening in the corner close to
happening
that's mate the bishop that dark square
bishop was in fact an animal 51 who 51
30 26 alrighty
all right let's keep soldiering on let's
get this advanced in with tempo that's
always nice to advance in the center
with an attack against a minor piece
alright so they lost some time there
this is a nice diagonal for the bishop
I'm expecting them to challenge my pawn
duo they're not so this is a passive
approach
let's went down well let's occupy an
open file first Bishop one of these two
okay I have a lead with my development
night here in 2f for good squares I want
to take with my pawn maintain the space
advantage
I could do this back up to c7 this is
similar to the last game huh put
pressure on there Bishop and night I
can't easily drop back now let's
maintain the pressure Knight c4 I
dropped back to c7 it's my queen they've
weakened their King position my knight
here is very good he give you some work
I could centralize with rook to d8 let's
do this they're securing their Knight b6
a 6 B 5 is an idea let's go for this
kick came out of out of here keep my
knight right where he's at
ok I'm not sure what that move is doing
okay all right now he's kicked away a
little bit uh-huh okay so they're gonna
take that night and know they had that
in-betweener they didn't go for it
though looking to invade a little bit
how no lets recapture rook here or rook
takes rook okay this is enormous Queen
here these dark square weaknesses are
too much I have this square protected
they missed that back to Turman 55 36 30
whoo it's a big one
as usual I did this last time with the H
fun let's open this up and continue to
move fast for sure okay huh
Knight here need some more development
I'm gonna start pushing me around or are
they inside Castle okay I'm in big
trouble
I gotta get my King off of here this
might just be barely working Oh
why'd I do that I was supposed to take
first that was terrible okay yeah that
was terrible terrible terrible terrible
yeah oh and now a slanted board could
you've waited for another opponents it's
already completely lost
the slanted board is the one thing I do
not need I promise you I definitely
don't need a slanted board oh yeah
slanted board that's exactly what I need
exactly what I need
yeah that's an enormous night enormous
night yeah there's a fork okay
they're gonna take my pond maybe I get
the rook oh that's the one thread I have
no trades keep pushing I get there pawn
I have a pond make them sweat
keep pushing I'm grabbing I'm dart
defending that that watch from a collar
I can't even name the pieces on on f7
here it's throwing a check how is this
even still going on now I'm winning not
for long now uh-oh
barely getting away with a draw Oh Oh at
64 38:32 how how do you manage draw how
did you do that no one no one has an
answer to that question right there I'm
sure everyone in the chat is raising
their hand listen they're just quit
asking questions that there isn't an
answer to why are you doing that guys
okay that's probably two weakening let's
throw a check in and get castled get
canceled would you run away get your
Bishop doing something exciting that's
how you do something exciting with your
bishop you run in Reverse okay
and we're gonna get rid of that guy and
we're gonna improve our King position a
little bit continue to do that
and give this night a kick he is done
that is enough it's hit the rook first
and then take here this was actually a
very good idea getting this piece now
Bishop takes Knight gonna have an active
rook but that should be short-lived
nope no activity it's to get these moves
in I guess oh honey let's give a check
back prove the king position very soon
very very soon
okay I'll go for a trade here you could
pre move a lot now watch out for the
sneaky pawn moves okay now I could be
assured that they have to move their
King let's just push through
now stalemates please no stalemates it's
here check next and then that's me back
to tournaments 69 69 41:34 who okay
let's do this
stop if I've they might be familiar with
that structure let's just not them not
allow them to play within that structure
it's not like a good one for me but I
didn't mean to do that
just trying to be a bit disruptive maybe
they're taken out of their comfort
comfort zone just a little bit okay I
get my Knight to c4 actually this is a
fine square Bishop c4 is excellent let's
keep the structure I'm hitting their a7
pawn they might fall into I wasn't
seeing that move but now I'm winning a
piece it's gonna say some bishop check
Knight g5 stuff could have been quite
good let's get out of the threat with
check back up Bishop c4 Knight g5 first
check Bishop c4 Knight g5 incoming
deadly threat very deadly threat get the
Queen I'll have to give up there rook
let's take care now we're getting the
Queen or some mate queen here I guess
check just push
not that it's take okay keep pushing and
that'll do it
okay back determine 73 41:36 hikes okay
I'm back on streak uh-huh less than five
minutes remain
okay okay I gotta do something a bit
more dangerous yeah I definitely have to
do something a bit more dangerous more
more sharp than this maybe I get
something if they take my bishop on g3
are they gonna do that maybe i clean
site castle line up some battery against
their king yeah let me try that bishop
back it reinforced my center bishop back
they removed a defender from their king
main threat bishop here i play you four
and let's hunt down their LightSquared
bishop I take here yet oh let's do this
and then push this age fun
I'm gonna keep my Queen and Bishop on
this dog and all if Knight takes to take
with the pawn it's ugly but there do it
actually if their Knight moves now its
mate let's go here okay
Queen here it's quicker than
site Castlerock h1 get my queen into h6
okay a queenside castle I think I need
one more piece no no I don't its mates
right here okay made on h8 what am I
talking about they have to move their F
on then I have check ok its mate next
they resigned back determined 78 44 44
points back hmm
this might be a moment to berserk
against whoever I'm paired up against I
gotta try it I got to try it
strong a strong opponent to do this
against and I don't feel and I have
enough speed to pull this off but we're
enough to give it a go get some free
moves in okay strike at the center okay
they're lining something up against Mike
King trying for that clean trade and
Rick activity I have this Knight move
might still be good be for some
sacrifice on d7 you know they're gonna
go for that gonna take my bishop two
minor pieces versus the rook situation
okay Knight f6 incoming let's get my
knight active I'm hitting the rook we're
doing good on the clock actually I
fought back clockwise let's get here
Rick b7 okay my knight is very active
okay they have a trade in here let's
take like this I don't want them to have
a passed pawn so easily 12 seconds
force this pawn to move no I got that
pawn give a check Knight here I'm
hitting the other pond I this is a win
objectively
keep pushing my king up okay I want to
give a check actually let's take this
pawn first I get their King out of their
check got there bishop I'll be doing on
the clock we got him Oh back to
tournament 4745 ah he's still up oh he
dropped his last game am I gonna get
paired up doesn't look like it I think
that's just how it's gonna finish oh
maybe maybe I'll bruise ERK and then
offer a draw
can you do that offer draw okay so this
wasn't a good idea for if you're looking
at rating point stuff cuz this one's not
gonna finish anyhow all right this has
never been seen before tactic that I
have lined up here never before seen
tactic fishing poles night there alright
let's see how you take okay I have that
covered enough all right let's keep
pushing here let's open it up a little
bit for my King to get killed I guess oh
that seems dangerous take my bishop
let's go here I guess they gave me their
dark-squared bishop clean check
somewhere here I guess
alright and I gotta back up no I'm not
backing up with that move crawling into
a ball now okay all right I'm not sure
what
to say it's very difficult here just
trying to go fast
yikes
okay avoid the Queen exchange if
possible oh that's not the way to do it
huh oh okay
back to tournament down on time they
have how many seconds in that one and
more than me final standings 250 not 256
yeah I imagine that 91 craziness 91 47
45 34 yo okay yeah 91 is way up there
interesting okay to the 73 of you into
her right around 55 at the start so some
late minute errs I guess GG's all all
right this is a new player at least I
haven't played against him before
perfect all berserks know not all
berserks but plenty of them berserk
great berserk win rate 52% games played
21 no all right that was intense
you